[Applaudissements]
tu ça sort mercredi au cinéma les tuche
2 s'est réalisée par mon ami olivier
baroux qui est excellent merci mont des
oliviers
merci double votre cadeau jusqu'après
jeu ce temps de se regarder alors ça
s'appelle la photocopieuse la
photocopieuse s'assure le titre on est
on est sur un type de travail mais ça a
évolué sept ans voire 15 progressent
pour ça qu'ils comprennent longer me
voilà mais regardez c'est très réussi
c'est parti et eux et donc j'étais en
loge de stylisme et à valérie arrive
pète un plomb salut fernand ça va et
c'est qu'ils ferment ses fils de charles
on l'apprend stage mabrier profile comme
la téloche
[Musique]
3 tu as vu ce délire et selon closer
matthieu delormeau dans les dix mecs les
plus sexy torse nu de france avec
cristiano ronaldo et ou quoi [ __ ] je
t'avais journalisme et moi je suis
combien toi tu es 97e et c'est vachement
bien
pas mal pas mal et cyril hanouna j'ai
pas un alors à 2380 deuxième juste après
louis la brocante
foot 8 chauffeurs
[Musique]
bebert tu tombes hyper bien t'as pas une
pièce de plus on fait une cagnotte pour
quoi faire
mon pote tu sais quelle prime tpm pv
cyril paye pendant toute l'année 2016
quelqu'un tirés au sort sur les réseaux
toutes ses factures son loyer tout au
tout et alors là c'est loin qui a été
tient au sur mon pote oh [ __ ]
d'accueil et pas de limites d'arrière
pensées mais du coup qu'est ce qui se
passe
il se passe que cyril bosse à mi temps
chez flunch ou
[Musique]
tain de bourrage papier ok fans de là
les caisses j'ai remplacé le numéro
d'hanouna par mon numéro dans le
portable delormeau et là bas alors je
pouvais tout ce que je veux tu as rien
vivre un truc mon petit mathieu ce soir
c'est au soir je veux absolument de voix
mais vient de préférence déguisés en
cow-boys j'ai toujours rêvé de te
chevauchée grand fou sans pantalon sans
pantalon pantalon smiley mutins salut
les gars voilà la bonne soirée en
costume un jeu pas vous en dire plus
sega mais ce soir ces mots soir
micheline good luck
on croise les doigts salut à toi prends
pas froid fait une belle rentrée cieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]